[Music]
so monar the legacy of Monsters has been
released with two episodes and now here
we will discuss about the opening scenes
of the very first one that was also
pre-released via certain YouTube
channels and this was a revisit to Skull
Island well mainly showcasing Randa Bill
Randa in the island and the claw versus
the mother longlegs as well as some
scenes that Kong was in but yeah mainly
the battle between the two gigantic
Creepy Crawlers and who was actually the
winner there so let's get to it let's
start with the mantle claws description
and size the mantle claw had the
appearance of a heavily armored crab but
they are stated to be vertebrates
meaning that even though they look like
crabs they have a skeleton underneath
along with a spinal column they do look
shorter at first due to their Crouch
stands but they can extend their body
upwards to be around 20 to 23 ft tall or
6 to 7 m the matal claw has a very
unique face its two eyes are in the
middle of the face covered by an armored
brow the coloration is a paler Brown
which Fades from the darker brown gray
of the armor hide its mouth is made out
of four pencils which are like
appendages arranged two on top and two
below and besides that it also has
pipals which are like those of a spider
that act like small arms it also has six
legs but they emerge from the central
part of the carpus on either side and it
has two Pines like those of a crab and
to add through that they also have
finger leg appendages which protrude
from beneath the claw so let's take a
look at the model long legs description
and size these long legs are giant
arachin species first featured in the
2017 film Kong Skull Island and again
here in the series these creatures stand
about 20 to 2 3 ft tall or 6 to 7 m they
have very long legs which resemble
bamboo stalks allowing them to
camouflage in the forest the bamboo
forest their faces look like skulls with
big red eyes and they have additional
pencil-like claws near their heads these
spiders use their sharp legs as Spears
to catch prey once they immobilize their
victim they inject paralyzing Venom
called the mother's milk absorbing
nutrients from the prey and they can
also draw moisture from the soil for
rehydration through the legs
additionally they have a special way of
capturing prey using muscular tendrils
that emerge from their underbelly
although the one seen in Skull Island of
2017 and this one from the series might
look terrifying they are nothing
compared to their Queen specimen which
was seen in the birth of Kong and was
around 150 to 200 ft in height a true
Titan in size so what are the powers of
the mantle claw this crap likee
vertebrate is more related to humans
than to crabs actually even though they
look more like the Crustaceans their
main advantage is their thick carapus
armor which is probably made out of
thick layers of chitan thus they only
have a few weak spots for rival monsters
to strike them down and actually hurt
them they are Ambush predators and also
filter feeders by the look of their
mouths and limbs this brings us to their
main offensive weapons which are their
pincers which are big and nasty as well
as having finger leg outg growths from
beneath the claws which gives them extra
grasping power and Mobility other than
that their sharp leg endings also can
Pierce to Stone which adds to their
deadliness and they also lead an
amphibious lifestyle in the water and on
land judging by where it is found on the
coastline and now what are the powers of
the mother long legs monar suggest that
the mother long legs might be a super
mutated version of a type of arachnet
called the opiliones it is stated that
there is no male specimen of the mother
longle hence their name
these giant spiders have a great Edge as
Ambush predators in the Lush bamboo
forest but even outside of them they are
seen to be F and very agile with
lightning F strikes using their many
legs and their small pencils that are
present in the front the legs are the
main weapons of defense against larger
opponents constantly stabbing and
lashing out which confuses the enemy
creature and creates an atmosphere of
panic to add to this they can also shoot
muscular tendrils from their bellies but
that's for smaller prey items but even
so they have another deadly weapon in
their Arsenal the mother's milk which
paralyzes smaller victims and might even
incapacitate the limbs and legs of
larger
monsters so how did the battle play out
and who actually won the fight well it
seems that the mother longle was out of
her element in the battle seeing that it
came out of the bamboo forest into the
territory of the mantle claw which is
the rocky Coastline anyway the fight
occurred the first strikes went to the
mother longle as her very fast strikes
seemed to overwhelm the movements of the
slower mantle crap Spencers which is in
his defense also had the heavy armor to
Shield it against most of the stabs of
the spider honestly the crap would have
had the upper hand in physical strength
due to its overall Mass but the one
crucial strike the spider made that
ended the struggling stalemate was when
one of her front limbs pierced the eye
of the crab this leg was immediately cut
off by the manle crab spincer causing
immense pain to the spider that drove it
to a Berserker rage pushing the
disoriented crap and herself off the
cliff into the ocean so this might look
like a wi for the mother long legs but
it's not quite so remember that now the
spider is deep underwater and now it's
the full element of the mantle crab
which would then Counter Strike and
counteract and finish off the drowning
arachnet bit by bit so who won probably
the mantle crab so yeah we also saw Kong
as well in the opening scenes of the
series but that's just to reaffirm the
events of Skull Island and randa's
overarching tale that will be explored
more in detail in the series we might
see glimpses of The Big Ape in footages
and maybe in Monarch screens but K will
hardly be here in the show unfortunately
that's what it is anyway that's it for
now if you like this video then watch
this other one as well and if you're
more interested in other movie monsters
and creatures then check out our Channel
we might just have things that you
haven't seen before like subscribe and
we'll see you in the next video take
care
fam